Smith works you know that but what's
this
well that is the Smith works mascot that
is which is me and it's got I don't know
I'm supposed to talk about this now
because there's all kinds of legal
issues so I'm just going to say let's
toast though because tonight y'all
is the voice finale what's disgusting
but it means pick me
everyone knows I'm gonna win I'm I'm
just kidding here you go okay I will say
most times drinking with you it doesn't
end well for me but it's mine and it's
awesome so you can't now this show would
be so much better if I could tell some
of the crap they just dream just think
about what could happen
that's it wait a minute what are we
toasting to the finale are the two T
Jake and Ricky yes
and I gotta say though I am amazed that
jake has made it that far with the worst
coach in the history of horrible
speaking of drinking there's so many
jobs like myself and you have is it
three restaurants right now and you're
opening a fourth there is uh so there's
a no red and in Tishomingo because it's
why is there one there because that's
that's kind of where I live yeah and
then that's why yeah and then there's
one in Knoxville and then there's one in
Gatlinburg and then we're about to open
one in Orlando and there's others in the
workplace to open one because of all the
stuff to do there's way smarter people
than me that decide where those things
go clearly really did you choose such a
mean guy I can't believe you did a shot
of vodka I can already tell you're
starting to actually I told him I said
there's no way she's gonna actually do a
shot of vodka I know I do tequila why
did tequila with Nick I've done the show
I've done Rosie with Chrissy Oh is
John's I drink a shot of Rosie no but I
drank I drank yeah I drink on the
addition was fun I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this